how in the world did these cost less
than a hundred dollars sound core by
anchor has been on a roll lately and
after using the new space ones I am
honestly impressed and in this video you
will not only get to hear my thoughts
and opinions on them but also get to
hear them for yourselves now when
soundcore reached out wanted to sponsor
a Showcase of these headphones I was
thinking to myself wow they're putting
out another pair of headphones so soon
but after using them it now makes sense
and honestly I'm kind of regretting
spending 350 bucks on the Beats Studio
Pro and I'll explain why now when I took
these out of the box my first impression
was wow they actually are presented
really nicely and wow they are really
lightweight now soundcore focused on
making these lightweight for a reason
it's gonna help with comfort and
reducing ear fatigue if you're gonna
wear these for a long time and of course
if you're going to work out that really
helps and of course having these be made
out of plastic that helps to meet that
Target price now speaking of the plastic
these do not feel cheap I actually had
both Vadim and Angelica hold both these
side by side before they knew the price
tag on these Sound Cores and both of
them said that they actually feel higher
quality than the creaky Beats headphones
do now a part of that reason is because
of this soft touch rubber material where
the headband actually goes down really
low and of course you can pull these out
to adjust them and then with that I
really liked that the ear Cups have this
textured material on the side it helps
with grip and it just feels nice and
then both the headband and the ear cups
are insanely soft I mean look how much
you can push on it this might be the
softest headband that I have felt and
all of that adds to comfort I wore these
for about four hours and I had no issue
with either the headband putting
pressure on my head or the ear cups
putting pressure on my ears and that's
also because sound Corp made these cups
adjustable so you guys could see there's
about eight degrees of change there so
they fit your head no matter kind of
what shape you have and one of my
favorite things is that they have dual
adjustable hinges here so they can go
out flat like airpods Maxes do and that
is great for having them hang out around
your neck like this and give you lots of
space to move around and just like the
beats the main reason I got them the
sound course can fold in like this for
very easy storage so I can easily slip
them into my bag whereas the airpods max
are a pain so you basically get the best
of both worlds now now unlike the Beats
when you are wearing these and you take
them off they will Auto pause if you
have the enabled in the app because they
have a sensor built into the ear cup to
be able to auto play and auto pause for
under 100 bucks compared to 350 where
you don't get that that is crazy and now
let's talk about noise cancellation and
these are surprisingly good sound core
focused on those mid to high frequencies
focused on voices and that's a lot
harder to cancel out compared to low
frequency sounds and they said that
compared to the last generation that
these are replacing these are twice as
good they also beat out the new Sony
ch720s especially in the mid to high
frequencies and those headphones are
more expensive than these now I went
into my local coffee shop and I put
these on and the active noise
cancellation did a really good job
reducing voices the sounds of the coffee
machines and even the terrible music
that they were playing now not only that
I've been working on my outdoor kitchen
even though these are not safety hearing
protection
um headphones they did a great job
because of that seal and the cuff
adjustment even without active noise
cancellation turned on they block out a
ton of sounds and then you can turn that
on to take it to the next level now of
course I also had to put it through the
torture test my very loud lawnmower and
they also did a really shockingly good
job for the price tag and honestly the
noise cancellation compares to
headphones that are two to three times
the price go ahead and take a listen how
they compare to the Beat Studio Pros
first I'll have it in the regular off
mode then active noise cancellation both
for airplane noise as well as a loud
coffee shop environment
[Music]
oh
now you can also enable wind noise
reduction and you can go in and
customize your noise cancellation I like
to Max it out but if you're sensitive
you can turn it down which is nice and
they also have adaptive noise
cancellation which will adjust the noise
cancellation based on the environment
and how much noise there is so it could
do so automatically they also have the
easy chat feature so you can put your
hand over the ear cup to lower down your
volume so you can hear who you're
talking to and you can use voice as well
where it will automatically enable that
and that is kind of crazy to think at
this price tag to have these features
now the transparency mode also works way
above its price tag we have three
microns built in and you can actually go
in and customize that as well I like to
keep it all the way up and voices don't
have that robotic sound a little
staticky sound that you will get from a
lot of lower priced headphones so I
would say they are very comparable to
the Beats which is crazy for the price
tag and now I have to touch on battery
life because it is really really good
these are rated for 55 hours in standard
in 40 hours with active noise
cancellation now the beats are rated 40
hours but that's in the standard mode
Once you turn on active noise
cancellation it drops down to 24 and
with that in just five minutes of
charging you get four hours of play time
compared to half of that with the beats
and less than half with the airpods max
so they have done a killer job and now
let's talk about sound quality these
have the same 40 millimeter drivers as
they do in the higher end headphones and
those sounded really good and so do
these now out of the box they're set up
in sound core signature and to me
they're a little bit too natural which
some people really like but I like a
little more low end and the highs to be
a little bit brighter so they have all
these different presets that you can use
but the good thing is you have a full
custom EQ so there is my preset I may
have went a little bit crazy on the base
here because I was listening to some EDM
and it sounded great but you have a full
range of customization and with that
setup these sound really really nice go
ahead and take a listen how they compare
bring me back to where we started
[Music]
now with that sound core also included
here ID where it will actually listen
and adjust based on your ears and give
you an optimized sound profile so you
can go through that habit tune it to
make them sound better for your ears
which is really cool and going through
the process it pretty much created an EQ
for me and adjusted for my ears and the
sound was similar maybe it was slightly
less bass than what I made for my own
custom EQ which is probably a good thing
and it just did a really good job so if
you're not good at going through and
creating your own eqs or you want
something that is based on you actually
just listening to what you like best
instead of trying to mess around this is
a really really cool feature now these
are the sky blue they also have jet
black and Latte cream as far as colors
and to wrap all this up I can constantly
say these are the best headphones you
can get under a hundred dollars and in a
lot of categories they beat up
headphones that are way more expensive
so let me know your thoughts down in the
comments section if you want to pick one
up we have links down below as well you
guys can try them out for yourselves I
think you guys are gonna be very
impressed and if you bought a pair let
me know your thoughts go ahead and click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those great videos right over
there that's been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]
all right